so fast company just released an article
on the four Creator economy trends that
we need to watch in 2023 and Fast
Company also named that the Creator
economy is the economy this year and so
uh let's dive into this but first of all
you know one of the questions I get all
the time is uh is it too late to start
YouTube and is it still a good time to
uh be creating content on YouTube and
let's just look at some of the recent
stats there's 2.6 billion monthly active
users on YouTube now in fact uh quite
specifically you can Target
2.56 mil billion people with the YouTube
ads platform as of October 2022 so in
2023 we just see these numbers going up
of just hard data of how many people are
logged in with an account
um the demand for good content is
skyrocketing rocketing YouTube is
available in over uh localized in 100
countries and available in 89 languages
but here's some cool news
influencer marketing Hub revealed that
this next year there's going to be a big
trend of micro influencers having a lot
of opportunity so a nano influencer
is someone with a thousand to ten
thousand followers Mega influencers have
millions of followers and micro are kind
of in between there and what they
discovered was that those following a
micro influencers recommendation are
more likely to take action and so
experts are predicting and I'm reading
here that smaller Industries will opt to
work with micro influencers because they
exude authenticity reliability
credibility which is today's audiences
value so let me know how many
subscribers do you have on YouTube right
now if you already started your channel
and this the cool news here is that
there's a big opportunity to make money
with a small channel in 2023
um 200 million people are earning money
from digital content creation right now
that's a massive number so 200 million
have made at least a dollar according to
this tube filter article and this is one
of the trends we're seeing small YouTube
channels are making big money now you
may have seen that this is the fastest
growing small business type that is
being a content creator and 2 million
Global creators have made six figures so
I know I'm throwing a lot of stats and
we're going to get into these Fast
Company four crater economy trends of
this article I just read in a second but
200 million have made at least a dollar
two million have made six figures and so
tens of thousands are making millions of
dollars and so some of the trends we're
seeing going into this next year here's
how also influencer marketing has been
growing in 2022 influencer marketing
reached
16.4 billion as an industry so look
what's happening every year do you see
the trend
and let me hit the like button if you're
getting value out of this video but
the trend is that every year influencer
marketing grows now you might be saying
Sean how does that help me though like I
haven't started making that money yet
well what we're Connecting the Dots here
is that the crater economy continues to
grow
more money is flowing into the crater
economy and when the influence for
marketing industry is growing where does
that money go some of it goes to the
agency if there's an agency that like
helps you get a brand deal
um and some of that could go to software
and different things but ultimately that
is the dollars that a brand pays to the
Creator
and the stat we just saw as this major
Trend that Nano and micro influencers
are going to be on the rise because
businesses understand they get a better
return on investment
of their dollars in terms of
um compared to investing like big money
in a huge influencer they get a better
engagement to you creating content on
your more Niche channel so pretty cool
and in fact in just a second we'll see
even deeper insights there and then
there's more monetization opportunities
coming
as far as YouTube shorts starts to
monetize on February of 2023. in
addition to regular channel monetization
that monetizes as well so here's what
we've been noticing is that YouTube is
healthy YouTube is growing and it is the
most profitable platform to establish
your brand this year and so let me know
if you have any predictions about
YouTube and um let me know uh what kind
of your goal is for YouTube in 2023
if you also heads up
um I'm doing a free class and that is
happening live today actually or there's
going to be a very limited replay if you
want to register it's at
thinkmasterclass.com I'm going to be
talking about the one strategy I would
focus on if I'm going to start or grow a
YouTube channel in 2023. it's going to
be live q a it's going to be fun so if
you want to check that out you can
register a link in the description as
well or if you're watching this on
Facebook the link should be in the
comments
um but a article came out from Fast
Company on the top four Creator economy
Trends to watch in 2023. there's another
article actually though just heads up if
you just read this headline the Creator
economy is the future
of the economy
now let me know if you agree with that
statement or not I'll just put that one
out there I mean I it's a pretty it's
pretty outlandish honestly but I think
it's something to pay attention to they
said that in November
the Creator economy is the future of the
economy I think of anything we could say
that if you're betting on creating
content if you're betting on building a
personal brand if you're betting on
creating content on YouTube so you can
get more leads and customers of your
business if you're investing in
starting a side hustle and creating
content on YouTube and other platforms
so that you can create extra income
you're making a pretty good bet I mean
when we're looking at just the data
what's happening and definitely
according to Fast Company here the
Creator economy is the future
of the economy but let's look at these
four Trends and I'm curious what you
would think about them here's what
they're noticing is um they're noticing
that according to influencer marketing
Hub the Creator economy is currently
valued
uh at 16.4 billion that's actually an an
erroneous stat because they were just
looking this as that influencer
marketing is valued at 16.4 billion the
crater economy is valued way more than
that Forbes says probably about 100
billion because
um
it's not just brand deals that goes into
it we're talking Google ad Revenue the
value of companies in the space it's
it's crazy the amount of money that's
flowing into that so if anyone wants to
message the editor of this that would be
influencer marketing is valued at that
not the actual entire crater economy
here's number one be being real like for
real so here's the first trend
I know we talk a lot about YouTube this
article is about four Trends to pay
attention to on the crater economy in
2023
authenticity may seem like an
overwrought buzzword but the sentiment
still Rings true for what audiences are
looking for
so there was a study done from United
talent agency IQ and the company found
that uh
one in two U.S consumers are interested
in seeing the process behind creating
content this is translated to an
audience's desire and a demand for the
Creator to pull back the curtain and
show their own life and show a level of
raw authenticity that's previously been
unprecedented you might have seen be
real the app be real as growing as a
trend
um in 2022 and that I think is speaks to
just this bigger demand and desire
for authenticity so being real like for
real is their point but basically number
one out of four is that authenticity
is a major Trend in
2023 to be paying attention to yes be
real Gabriel saying uh living for
longevity Cheryl says 100 authentic uh
yeah Jesse good to see you Merry
Christmas yeah I think that uh we are
bit we've been thinking about this and I
think that fake is getting exposed in
culture of course the internet kind of
Reveals All eventually and
um the more real and raw and vulnerable
uh I think we could be in our content
even the better in fact Friday on the
think media podcast if you're not
subscribed definitely subscribe we have
a Trends episode coming out it's much
more tactical and then next week there's
one coming out on kind of the more
emotional side and authenticity is one
of those big things not just my opinion
fast companies saying it
um
I uh Fast Company saying it HootSuite
HubSpot some of these other firms are
are seeing that that kind of let your
hair down more raw content is gonna be a
big Trend do you agree do you disagree
uh the Z fund shows 100 percent agree be
real with yourself and have fun uh
really good so that's that's number one
out of the three number two is Mass
Appeal is dead so here's what they say
over the past few years micro and even
Nano craters that is to say those with a
few hundred hundred or a thousand
followers began to claim their territory
in the crater economy in a meaningful
way as markets marketers have learned
subscriber and follower accounts are
important but engagement rates are even
more so and the research has shown that
creators with smaller followings aft
often have higher engagement rates
so that's kind of a cool side note uh
and that is that one of the reasons why
micro influencers perform better is if
you've grown your audience in a specific
Niche and you're really connected and
loving on and in engaging with your
audience there's more power there than
maybe somebody who grew multiple
millions of followers probably a large
percentage of their followers or Bots
fake followers not because they did
anything but just because of maybe how
the internet works and the engagement
rate compared to how many followers
versus how many people take action there
might be a breakdown there or there
there is that's what the data would show
us but Mass Appeal is dead what do they
mean here
so the rise of Niche community and
subcultures is one of the biggest things
we're going to see continue to grow and
is most important with so much out there
it's not enough to appeal to everyone
anymore you have to
it's not enough to appeal to everyone
anymore you have to appeal to a specific
audience in order to move the needle so
Mass Appeal is dead and uh it's funny
fast companies saying this is going to
be a new trend going into 2023 but I
think that uh this is kind of an age-old
marketing saying they say the riches are
in the niches
and uh I do think the Nuance here though
of tapping into subcultures
tapping into more Niche communities the
cool thing about the internet is it
affords us the opportunity to go deep in
weird Niche communities for example
there's the Lord of the Rings Channel
and
they've been doing their thing because
there's the old movies The Lord of the
Rings there's the three Hobbit movies
there's the books different stuff comes
out there's a card game people are
rallying around it but who would have
thought that then Amazon Prime would
invest a bunch of money by the right
start a new show and then boom people
that are into rings of Power are now
reinvigorated around Lord of the Rings
that channel has a whole bunch of new
content to create that's a niche
subculture super fans and and Casual
fans and new fans of The Lord of the
Rings it's a subculture and of course
there's different subcultures biohacking
all these different types of things are
you a part of any subcultures I'd say
I'm a part of biohacking I literally
have red light therapy panels behind me
on the wall so you know
that's just I've got literally liver
King and apparently apparently I should
just take steroids inside instead
because these liver King pills were not
the key to getting his physique I was
scammed just kidding no I'm down I think
liver is still good for you and and uh
I'm into the marketing whatever I'm part
of subculture I'm in that kind of that
bio hacking world uh whatever and so um
uh let me know what some of the
subcultures you're a part of Keto for
sure I feel that uh my friend Ben is
into that he gets me into all kinds of
stuff we're talking about pemf Maps
right now and all kinds of different
stuff so let me know what some of the
stuff you're a part of
um number three in just a second that
we're gonna get to but I see if you're
just joining live smash like and we're
talking about number one is be real like
for real and so this was Fast Company
talking about authenticity as being the
first big Trend behind the scenes being
vulnerable being authentic being raw in
your content and not just having overly
polished content number two Mass Appeal
is dead tapping into a subculture
tapping into a more specific Niche the
world is so noisy the world is so busy
content is there's so much content by
being more specific
you can actually really engage an
audience that wants that exact thing and
we have so many options we want the
exact thing we want we don't want
General we want specific I think it was
actually Zig Ziglar who said don't be a
Wandering generality be a meaningful
specific there's a good summary for
2023. if your YouTube channel is a
Wandering generality you might be in
trouble if your YouTube channel is I'm a
meaningful specific to a specific group
of people and specifically to a
subculture you're on the right track
um okay let's get into number three in
just a second but if you as a reminder
if you didn't hear about the free class
I'm doing I'm going live uh in our about
a two hour class Melissa Caputo's there
we're giving away an entire YouTube
Studio it's gonna be a lot of fun I'm
doing live q a and some other stuff
that's happening thinkmasterclass.com if
you want to register for that we're
getting ready for 2023. it's gonna be a
lot of fun and live q a whatever else
Link in the description or the social
media notes let's look at what number
three is here according to fast
Company's top four crater economy Trends
to watch in 2023
the rise number three
of the curation of the curator economy
okay
so also pushing against the Deluge of
Mass Appeal is the rising need for
curation this is one of the ones that I
think you learned some of the most
nuanced strategy and one of the biggest
opportunities for you
so according to a study half of U.S
adults said they feel overwhelmed by the
surplus of content on streaming services
alone at other mixed media to the mix
such as books podcasts social content
the crisis of choice is compounded
audiences want to know they're spending
their time wisely with social media
platforms so they aim uh
Which social media platforms aim to do
with algorithmically chosen content but
Smith sees an opportunity for creators
to be the human equivalent of an
algorithm wow this is profound
Smith sees the opportunity for creators
to be the human equivalent of an
algorithm
I'm actually trying to do that now now
that I think about it's pretty meta I'm
I am you subscribe to the think media
podcast because you want to stay
informed about YouTube about the Creator
economy I'm pulling together lots of
Divergent data sources and I'm bringing
you trends that I hope are valuable to
you in relation to being prepared for
2023 you don't necessarily have time
because you've got all kinds of things
to do so why do you subscribe to think
media podcast so I can bring you the
news in regards to what's happening
anyways so ultimately how could you do
this in your same Niche and and bring be
the human equivalent of an algorithm for
people Okay so we've seen a ton of
creators themselves leaning into the
space to provide curated recommendations
for an audience that loves them aligns
with their tastes and wants to be close
to them by consuming what they consume
so what we're seeing here is that and
they give some examples hypebeast hype
Bay High snowbiety and uh some of these
other kind of taste makers that be
related to
fashion music and things like that
but here's the big opportunity on the
rise of the curator economy maybe you've
seen faceless channels or YouTube
automation channels a lot of times we'll
talk about the top 10
places to travel they'll use OPC other
people's content not OPP like Naughty by
Nature OPC where you can use fair use
and drop other people's content we got
Evan Carmichael here who says I love
content creation yes indeed and so Evan
Carmichael is a curator
of incredible content he'll theme
multiple Divergent sources
related to health mindset wealth and
he'll curate that because who has the
time to go watch 30 hours of personal
development when Evan and his team can
turn that into 33 minutes for you simply
doing that is the opportunity a major
opportunity it's been an opportunity but
in 2023 as the world gets noisier if you
can bring curation to uh YouTube there's
just unlimited opportunity there and
it's like we need curation on curation
you know as sometimes people love the
long form video podcast but some people
just want the highlights and as you
begin to understand fair use law
you start to realize the opportunity of
again using
multiple different content sources
combining it into something new and I
mean I know countless people that are
making one two three four five 10K a
month per YouTube channel they have
multiple YouTube channels curating
things or their main business their main
YouTube channel is curation and they're
uh you know bringing in just YouTube ad
Revenue Alone
by curating other people's content
I mean uh furthermore have you seen one
of my favorite channels called uh
the internet today on the internet
what's the show called it's like uh this
is your daily dose of the internet daily
dose of the internet what is that it's
like the internet is so much stuff out
there and who can show me number three
is the rise of the curator economy who
can show me the stuff I missed the cute
little animals the really crazy stunts
people pulled off and they pull in tick
tocks and they pull in uh YouTube clips
and they pull in stuff from all kinds of
random places nice little narration
what is fail blog you don't need to be
Danny Tanner anymore and do
America's Funniest Home Videos you don't
need to be Rob Dyrdek and do
Ridiculousness you can just be
Brad living at home in an apartment with
the internet connection and a laptop and
you can make a multiple thousands of
dollars earning YouTube channel by being
a curator if you can download content
edit it mix it yes that's a rabbit hole
of you might have a million questions
and that's not the point of today if you
do want to do some more q a uh join me
at thinkmasterclass.com I'll be going a
little bit deeper I gotta get to number
four but the rise of the curator economy
is a major one and uh I would
uh definitely want to go deeper in that
Jackie says would be awesome to do a
fair use video that's good uh uh adding
that to the list and if you have any
video recommendations drop them in the
live chat or the comments
um would love to uh connect there more
and Jaya am I saying your name right
Jaya
agreed uh fair use guideline video and
yeah you could dig it it's a pretty big
rabbit hole I'll probably I'll bring
some guests on
to uh think media podcasts in regards to
uh uh fair use in 2023 it's an evolving
industry as well but it's a majorly
important thing for you to know and
understand Jesse says curation feels
like back in the day when we promoted
RSS feed subscriptions yes and you know
one way I'd like to summarize this in
the past as far as the rise of the
curation economy is
um
really
I mean I know a lot goes into creating
YouTube content but one of the biggest
opportunities when you just think about
what makes a successful YouTube video
is the fact that if you spend 10 20 30
hours
in research in collecting footage and
shooting footage shooting b-roll or and
Gathering other media sources in
studying and listening to
uh like Evan does on Evan Carmichael's
Channel you know if he's gonna do Gary
vaynerchuk's top 10 or 20 or 30 or 40 or
50 roles of success
there might be 50 hours of content to
put 52-minute Clips altogether plus the
intelligence to know which Clips are
even really good or correlated and
having a system for that or doing it
yourself so when you think about what
makes a good YouTube video if you can
save people time
if you can take 30 of your hours and
consolidate that into eight minutes and
put that on YouTube and the end user
just didn't have to take the 30 hours
but you delivered them the information
then what happens
viewer satisfaction people go wow this
video is well researched it was well put
together and so you might go that sounds
painful I got to do the video editing I
got to do all the research I got to put
all the time in and it is painful but
that's what people are paying for
they're paying for your pain how are
they paying they're paying with their
time how are they paying they're paying
with their watch time and when they pay
with their watch time and their
click-through rate because you just gave
them great content the viewer
satisfaction is high then it spreads on
YouTube and one video gives you leverage
because yeah it took you 30 hours to do
it you edited all that down into eight
minutes of value for the viewer
but as it spreads on the internet that
one video can then pay you
500 a thousand video a thousand dollars
two thousand dollars three thousand
dollars now you're getting a thousand
dollars for ten hours of work just
getting a hundred bucks an hour from one
video eventually and the thing with
YouTube is hustling at the start because
you're like I did spend 30 hours Sean
and my video got three views I don't I'm
not even monetized yet bro what are you
talking about you as you put in the work
and you put in the due diligence and you
put in the hustle and you're patient the
goal is that you hit that Tipping Point
where you can post one video
and it can then produce for you ongoing
reoccurring Revenue I think that's the
other key is it's not just it's not so
transactional and you make the video
once and it can never be viewed again
when you do especially your content
according to the think media methodology
you're creating videos today that work
for you and pay you and get you views
for weeks months and years to come so
anyways the rise of the curation economy
number three I don't mean to go so long
on that but uh this one's pretty
exciting and I think that even s
I would argue that we are both and we're
not either or you don't even have to
just be a curator Channel
you can also add this type of content
even if you're not a curator like why
not also add just a curation video
does that make sense like I mean
I suppose we had when we had Gary
vaynerchuk speak at our event that made
sense he's coming to our event but
whether he was or not I made a video in
Evan Carmichael style called
garyvee's top seven YouTube tips and I
was like Gary hooked it and I was like
hey uh you know welcome to garyvee's top
seven YouTube tips let's get into number
two and I just narrated it like Evan
Karma and and so that's fair use because
I did the due diligence of studying
every video I could find to see when
Gary talked about YouTube so I
contextualized there might not there's
only a handful of people who would even
make that video because it'd be
Irrelevant in other niches but that's
makes that's my promise to you is the
best YouTube advice so me curating and
Gathering other stuff even though I'm
here solo-rounding not curating you can
do both okay going a little long on this
but uh smash like if you're getting
value on the conversation and uh let's
keep in it moving uh Gabriel asked if a
view watches a video more than once does
YouTube Count it's as much as the ad
play it might count in terms of views it
might the view counter might go higher
but if you're talking about in terms of
earning money you you only earn money
when an ad plays
and if there's ad blocker that hurts and
a lot of times if you watch a video an
ad won't play again necessarily if you
watch the video twice or it may so it's
just when the ad plays Tony says you're
giving me ideas thanks Sean my man I
appreciate you Tony and seriously I do
want to thank you Tony for
um being a part of our community being
engaged in the comments I see you I love
it when I see your avatar and uh uh you
like Swedish car guy like some of you
who've been rolling with us at think
media for years and just dropping love
and dropping comments like thank you for
the love it means the world and I know
your time is valuable
um and your attention could go a lot of
different places so thanks for being a
part of our community and just sending
you massive love and respect going into
2023 let's hit number four
on this Fast Company article on the four
crater economy Trends to watch in 2023
number four all right number four is
short form shopping we initially saw an
appetite for short form content when
vine Reigns Supreme in 2013.
and tick tock's dominance over the past
three years has shown that there's still
high demand
but the sticking point for short form
content creators has been how to
monetize
YouTube created an industry standard of
pre-roll and mid-roll ads which doesn't
quite translate to one minute videos but
as a side note
of course
monetization is coming to shorts
in 2023
and the way they're doing it is they're
going to have like clusters of videos
that your short will be associated with
so you like watch a short you watch
another one and then you watch an ad
a short will play that is a sponsored
post and then you watch another short
and then you watch another short and
somehow YouTube will pay
that batch
so whoever was in that little cluster
will get paid
for people who are paying for their
sponsored short posts
it's my understanding of how it works
correct me if I'm wrong so so mid roles
it's really mid-rolls mid and the mid
roll is not the middle of a short
because Short's already a little too
short they're in between two shorts
playing so essentially mid-rolls are
going to be what it is but that's not
what this is saying the fourth trend is
short form shopping
while creators earning revenue is always
welcome CEO and co-founder of clutch
says that creators are going to see an
increase of short form creators selling
directly through their content
so e-commerce platforms like
kalarna
and Shopify rolled out programs that
connect creators to Merchants directly
so when people say tick tock made this
made me buy this you don't think Amazon
wants to say the same thing we see short
form video as being an incredible
conversion tool for consumerism
and so what this point is saying is that
short form will drive sales and that
there which should be increasing
opportunities for there to be an
e-commerce experience on short form as
an anti anecdotal side note we have done
a YouTube short and we track all of our
affiliate links with genius links and
one of our YouTube shorts is crushing in
regards to how many people have clicked
the link and purchased this tech product
that the Short's about which I still
can't fully understand because let me
know do you ever go to the description
on YouTube shorts It's a rare place that
people go because it's kind of hard to
get there you're going through your
YouTube shorts got to like click the
three dots and like open and like go
there nevertheless that's not what this
is talking about because that's kind of
a janky experience I think what we'll
see is in these short form platforms
the integration of e-commerce of the
ability to see a product highlighted of
something that someone's interested in
and that that shopping experience is
more streamlined that's the fourth
biggest prediction that uh they're
making over here on um
Fast Company and so
which one stood out to you uh best I if
you have a question put four question
marks before and after your question
um number one is authenticity being real
like for real number two Mass Appeal is
dead number three the live the rise of
the curator economy if you're just
joining re-watch that part because that
one's some serious opportunity for you
in 2023 number four
short form shopping is the fourth one
um before I answer a couple questions I
will be back going live in three hours
uh it's actually in kind of a private
viewing page because I'm going to be
teaching exclusive content that we
normally teach just inside of our video
ranking Academy for for totally free you
can register at think masterclass we're
also giving away a YouTube studio
and we are doing Q a so if you're not
registered for that that is happening at
thinkmasterclass.com
um we're going to be giving away this
kit as well
um a great webcam it's like a live
streaming kit q2u microphone newer light
kit details in the post or in the show
notes so definitely check those out and
I appreciate you Swedish Car Guy
um and
let's see
uh if you got questions you know how we
do it here we go four question marks
before and after
video idea genius links breakdown I want
to better track my Amazon Affiliates and
other affiliate links great video ideas
coming this way I like it it's in that
crazy week between Christmas and New
Year so it's like kind of your planning
your goal setting and so I like that one
fair use videos more affiliate marketing
videos absolutely
um fair use breakdowns bring some guests
on to talk about all the above
um love that
that Master Class bumps right into
Omar's Workshop any thoughts on his
Workshop I you're right I forgot Omar's
doing a workshop Omar is launching a
brand new thing if you come out to Vegas
you got to check out the video
Department that's a separate project
that Omar's doing on his own he's
opening up um a uh uh a he already has
opened it I don't know if it's open open
but he's finished it up he's got a cool
location where you can rent it out film
a podcast shoot some incredible
thumbnails
um if you're not following Omar El
takori on social media do it he's a
great follow and of course you'll see
his videos on our main Channel think
media
Hannah when do I know to double down on
my content as a new creator
well Hannah it's a really good question
it's kind of a time management question
um and uh priorities
management question so Hannah what I
would ask is and this is kind of a
workshop we could all do here together
especially as we prepare for 2023 is
first you just write down like what are
the biggest priorities in your life and
if you have 10 priorities you have no
priorities so there's different seasons
for different priorities and so you
first say okay I definitely ought to go
to work because if I don't I won't make
money can't and I won't pay my rent and
then I'll be on the street so you're
like I gotta go to work I got to take
care of my health and I'm going to focus
on YouTube and then you might be like I
gotta go to work I got to work on my
health I got two side hustles I want to
do this and I want to do YouTube you
might want to eliminate some priorities
if they're eliminatable
we call it the law of sacrifice like
what what are you going to sacrifice for
YouTube so all that to say is that it's
an audit of your time first Hannah it's
saying
how you might not be able to double down
on content if you don't have the time so
do you have the time can you carve out
the time what can you sacrifice to
create the time
the second thing and finally Hannah is a
it's kind of a test and it's the
momentum test it's
is there notable momentum that you
should lean into
and even take a little bit of a risk on
so I would call this we call it the 25
rule
so it's like when should you go all in
on YouTube and the 25 rule is step one
how much money do you need to make a
month to
pay your rent pay your bills and survive
um that states four thousand dollars the
25 rule is when you are making a
thousand dollars
on your YouTube channel or as a Creator
on a side Hustle
that is a signal that you should maybe
double down and go all in
so practically I would step one Define
okay I need five four thousand dollars a
month and that's just for easy math for
me so whatever that is for you
step two I go okay I have to go to work
and I work 40 hours on my job right now
and uh that's where I get my four
thousand but while I've been working at
my job and doing my other
responsibilities I have also been able
to side hustle my way up to a thousand
dollars a month of online income now
that's not enough to pay all my bills
but the fact and here's the principle
the fact is if you can hit that 25 of
your needed monthly expenses while doing
it as a side hustle you have verifiable
momentum that if you were to give your
two weeks notice
I believe that you would be able to
close the gap of the remaining 75
percent really fast it's what my
experience has been as well when I made
the leap and lost my freelance clients
and I went all in
the money was very I was making around
700 a month and about
one month about 45 days later of
hustling only on my YouTube channel
I made up the remaining 75 basically
the key is I already had momentum and
the key is I'd already proven it that I
could do it as a side hustle and here's
the big scary moment is you've proved
you can do it as a side hustle so then
imagine when it's your only hustle
imagine when you just you stopped doing
everything else you give your two weeks
you finish up at work you go all in and
one other ingredient here is wise money
management and some savings you want to
have enough savings that buys you one
two three months four five six months of
going all in because there's really two
seasons to be in there's the side Hustle
season there's a solopreneur season and
there's ultimately the scale season but
when you're in the side Hustle season
that leap to this being your only thing
it's a game changer and I bet you can
imagine you're like well obviously
that'd be really cool but it's just like
then you don't even work just 40 hours
on it when you're like desperate you got
to make it work you can work 50 60 70
hour weeks at the start to close that
financial gap so that's kind of some of
the self-awareness uh stuff I would do
is um is kind of say what are my
priorities and then I would say
how much do I need to live on a month
what would it am I seeing any verifiable
momentum and if I am
this is why entrepreneurship in the
definition of Entrepreneurship is the
word risk if you look up the word Google
it to Webster's it's like someone who
takes on
abnormal amounts of risk to start a
business Endeavor or Venture so starting
a YouTube channel becoming a Creator and
really going all in
it is spelled eventually r-i-s-k there's
risk involved but what it doesn't mean
is it doesn't mean being careless it
doesn't mean that it's not calculated
risk or it also doesn't mean that you're
just like I hope this works that that
verified momentum actually is like no
this is probably going to work
uh it's probably guaranteed to work
because if I can do this in very part
time with my
very like my energy afterward when I'm
tired you've already worked 40 hours and
on your side hustle juggling all your
other responsibility you were able to
get your thing to 25 of your needed
monthly income what happens when you're
fully rested and that's like the only
thing you're thinking about it grows a
lot faster than you would think so it's
still a risk it's still scary it's still
not a guarantee that it's gonna work but
that's I think the best play-by-play way
to really think through it in terms of
of taking the leap and so I appreciate
that you uh have got some value out of
kind of that that that formula and I
also share that with you because
you know you might have family members a
spouse a partner
somebody that just doesn't get it you
know it's like
you're like uh you know I wanted this
YouTube thing I want to join the Creator
economy and they're looking at you like
what the heck are you talking about you
want to join the Creator what's the
Creator economy you know what I mean
like you try to have a conversation with
somebody you're like no like for real
this is the fastest growing small
business type and they're like what are
you saying you want to be a tuber Uber
boober
wow that sounds is that even a real job
and and with respect I get it like
people don't understand this
so what I want to encourage you is do
your due diligence do your research
share the data share Fast Company
articles share share Fast Company which
is a reputable business publication
saying that the Creator economy is the
economy
and then share the math and plan on
paper with
key people in your life to say listen
this isn't just a pie in the sky pipe
dream where it feels like I'm being just
irresponsible or neglecting things or
that I just a dreamer and there's not
practicality to with this this is a a
real thing I'm thinking through sure
there's risk it's not guaranteed to work
but honey let me break this down let's
break this down together and especially
if you could prove to people in your
life that instead of just dabbling away
your extra time frittering away your
extra time on a hobby that's not
paying you or not building up your brand
or something that you do take a few
extra hours hit 100 subscribers hit a
thousand subscribers
earn a couple hundred dollars a month
that's some crazy
evidence
if you're going to someone in your life
I I know it's hard because you probably
have people who don't believe in you or
you have people that you feel
unsupported by or you have people who
you're you wish
somebody saw the vision you see or they
supported your dreams more I I get it
sometimes people can just kind of truly
be ultra negative and pulling you down
and it sucks because you wish you had
more of a cheerleader but sometimes too
they're just generally skeptical or
cynical and they're they're just they
care about you and they don't want to
see you waste your time or whatever so
the key is that you would show them
evidence you go listen
nothing to really like brag about yet
there's nothing crazy yet but I have a
756 subscriber YouTube channel and all
my other responsibilities I've been
uploading a video pretty much every week
an average of three a month and so I
miss a week because I'm juggling so much
but I've been I've been consistent and
what I'm saying I'm gonna do I'm a
person of my word my yes has been yes I
said I was going to do YouTube as a side
hustle and I've been consistent and I've
grown my channel to cover 100
subscribers and I've putting out an
average of one video a week like three a
month and I've even dropped some
strategic videos I got some affiliate
links out there and I've made 22 dollars
that's super significant because there
is evidence that you follow through that
you do hard things that you put in the
work that you work when you're tired
that you do it when you don't feel like
it and you do it when you do feel like
it and at least you still might not get
the most support from people around you
but at least at that moment you
ultimately have some things you can
point to and then you'll be surprised
that people might start rallying around
and your own confidence will build as
well to take that leap when it comes to
ultimately being a creator
um and uh
yeah I feel you my parents think that
this is BS like your dad just said it
yesterday and you know three years in
you still don't make any money so why
don't you quit that hurt a lot I'm sorry
that they said that and I think that you
know look inside
uh said with empathy I think there's
also something about
listening to data points that's not the
only data point but it's a big data
point there's something about listening
to it
and using it as fuel not as some like to
keep creating content and potentially to
Pivot to say okay what
can I learn from that and how might I
pivot and I want to recommend Swedish
Car Guy
um the video if you search on this
channel think media podcast when to quit
um it's based off a book by Seth Godin
called the dip and ultimately he says
that the we don't quit but we do pivot
that's a huge key if you're three years
in
and not seeing that momentum I was just
talking about I would argue you need to
Pivot
pivoting to a different Niche pivot
remember I've got like four Failed
YouTube channels
on my journey to one successful YouTube
channel now multiple but I mean at the
time when I really so
I've pivoted a lot I have stopped doing
certain projects never gave up on the
vision but stopped doing certain
projects or stop doing certain channels
as I learned that sometimes you win
sometimes you learn failures are the
Stepping Stones to success so it's not
just saying like oh I give up I think
that there is literally an unlimited
opportunity in YouTube there's unlimited
different ways to do it there's a
personal brand way the faceless way
there's being a channel manager for
somebody else there's the video there's
video production there's working for
other influencers like being involved in
the Creator economy is literally I think
something everybody could do not
everybody's necessarily going to be like
a charismatic front person that is doing
it exactly like the way you see
everybody else doing it and what does
that mean that means that we may pivot
we go okay
the vision is still the same but what it
looks like is a little bit different
than I thought my goal is actually still
the same but my execution of the goal my
approach to the goal is maybe going to
change a little bit but check out that
video uh on the think media podcast it's
here on the channel it's also on the
audio on
ultimately uh
when to quit look that up like quit
think media should bring that video up
um what's the best webcam
I really love this new anchor webcam
this is like less than 50 dollars
so you can look that up I forget the
model name but you can see it's got the
cool little red privacy filter thing
um and then I think that the Logitech
Brio if you want to go 4K this is 2K
it's a little bit bigger than 1080 in
terms of resolution but uh and and the
price is unbeatable but Logitech Brio
it's kind of glitchy sometimes but it's
pretty good and by the way we're giving
away this kit
on the master class happening a little
bit later today thinkmasterclass.com
that's a live class that I'm going to be
doing I hope you can join me it's going
to be a lot of fun
um and smash like if you are getting
video today Maria it's good to see you
appreciate you and
um thanks for being a part of the stream
smash like if you're getting value and
check out the replay top four Creator
Trends to watch in 2023 from Fast
Company we also opened up with a bunch
of stats that I just researched in terms
of uh 2023 influencer marketing how much
money is falling into the crater economy
a lot of opportunity and so um smash
like if you liked the video subscribe if
you're not subscribed and then also
click or tap the screen I did a video on
my personal five YouTube trends that you
need to know it's actually on the think
media channel if you click at the screen
you can watch that my name is Sean
Cannell rhymes with YouTube channel I
look forward to seeing you in a future
video and if I don't see you before New
Year's happy New Years we'll talk soon
peace